- Your husband just released
a new book featuring immigrant
paintings and stories.
When he started painting, he
wasn't as good as he is now,
I've heard, so how did you, as a teacher,
encourage his work or was
this like the speeches
and you just laid low?
- I laid low.
(laughing)
But actually he's really gotten good.
I'm shocked, I mean he was
not interested in art at all.
The White House has a major
collection of American art
and of course he never
really looked at it.
So I was very surprised
when he took up painting
but he's gotten to be really good.
That was one of his first paintings.
- [Kelly] That's amazing.
- But now of course,
these are the portraits
of immigrants that are at
the Bush Center in Dallas.
And I wanna invite everybody,
come to the Bush Center
and see the paintings.
They're immigrants that you know
like Henry Kissinger or Madeline Albright,
or then people that you don't know
that have immigrated to the United States
and it's their paintings, their
portraits and their stories.
- Oh man, they're beautiful.
I have tried so hard to paint.
I tell you what, I am the worst at it.